alright let's talk about the NRA and no
I'm not talking about the National Rifle
Association i'm talking about.
the NRA the National Restaurant
Association which might be slightly more
dangerous believe it or not
this is a political lobby representing
the nation's largest
food service companies and they're one
of the most powerful
lobbyist on capitol hill they get a lot
of crazy
shit done let's take a look okay so they
have nearly 52,000 members and
this includes Olive Garden
Red Lobster Starbucks things like that
they have a PR firm berman company which
is famous for opposing sensible public
interest in safety was
a their leaders are in Fortune 500
companies and they have a budget
up sixty five million dollars and employ 40 lobysits okay so on its face
nothing here sound that bad is just how
america worked but
so there's a lot of information here so
you can pause it and read it on your own
but some other things that they've defended pink slime in burgers which
we talked about
inhumane conditions for poultry they've
opposed industry pledges
to raise pigs humanely babe oppose
Paycheck Fairness Act for
waiters and waitresses Pregnancy
Discrimination Act and they block the
federal minimum wage increase
for restaurant employees they found a
loophole to exclude employees from the
new health care law
all kinda stuff I am and and there's a
lot more and I
nobody talked about this and you know we
talk about lobbying money about it all
the time
here but I thought this was thirty
interesting because he brings it
literally
to our table write the stuff that we're
putting in our body yeah
the step right there um should be no
more
about the National Restaurant
Association did you know about this
before week's end you guys Martin Way
other I in full disclosure word for
Olive Garden when I was in high school
so I'll really
yeah I know I knew we were partly an RA
yeah other yeah name because we are so
38 NRA without a single loving
what is it that way like high night like
hiding in plain sight
right but was it wasn't you know the WWF
used to be the World Wrestling
Federation in the World Wildlife
Federation stepped in and then the WWF
threatening one
became World Wrestling Entertainment
resigning so should we force
this either an array to get another name
so we can all focus on them alone
understand them and no
get a good look at them the hasher yeah
week or move any any further what we
need to know about the unlimited
salad it's too good to be true right
light hours a day
you know it the way he what you know
what you can switch the felony you can
switch the super free
what you mean for what like it goin
limited soup salad and breadsticks
yeah I get like want have a solid and
then it still unlimited be honest but it
was these are a few won both the
minestrone
and until I yes limited gonna a venir o
wow
yeah you well you know when you're here
either been reported yeah there you go
I'm OK
had so yes so it shouldn't surprise us i
suppose that a lobbying
that a you know dissociation like this
would use lobbying to do all these
horrible thing
we shouldn't we know about this should
we be talking about why this never
discussed
it's funny because week we talk about
the stories like Papa John's opposing
and Obamacare and saying oh to cripple
is the
but then finding out it doesn't we think
I go out and do it okay that I did a
million overnight cool but when we
learned there's a poll lobby
scouting are these ideas across the
industry United one
one billionaire yeah the should the
government
why is the government so involved in our
who isn't that like the bigger problem
here that we've so separate ourselves
from our food source you know you mean
we don't do any
kinda farm to table stop so that of
course you when you have all these
middlemen matter
a you know putting laws in that allow
for all these chemicals and all that
other stuff and you
the big question why the government
among our food the necessary for
survival
I'm you know in the same way that it's
involved in our here in keeping it clean
supposedly I'm
but it's also motherhood for profit
because it has a lot of corporate
interest to print acting mean look at
the dairy industry the something that
they get
agriculture it I'll at the place where
they
can make a lot of money and politicians
get a lot of money from these
corporations so it matters than
yeah so money in politics of course
among other things that I thought was
interesting
is that they bought against lower sodium
levels in food
which the generally they say lower
sodium
maybe for you that's good that's why me
wanna fell more food and they won their
products to beat 50
oh so you're saying that the NRA is not
in it for public good
they're in it for us to buy more up
there shit
I mean are the unit with this all people
like you know to me like that just isn't
just one big clusterfuck
I know I'm sure if we look for their
will find that there is profit to be
had. in certain areas than that that's
why it's happening
what drives me crazy is that they were
fighting to keep tipped
server wages solo and two and fighting
the minimum wage increase
yeah I'm in other countries you know
liked it for what for the tipping think
yeah there
they're kinda they don't encourage
tipping
our it looked upon it at more you know
ago you think I would go to my job
yeah epic moreover something you cannot
overwrite prideful at the vineyard
your work sooo waiter yeah well speaking
about dad did you guys know that youtube
is gonna start putting a tip jar
right over there so and gets it or doing
here
you could just it's not there yet I
don't think
up